welcome to this video playing PT Capri
PT Capri andreas k Lyris no pet I don't
know that guy I am I got two wins zero
losses one hundred percent so let's try
to keep this score what is Capri
actually pity I know but yeah my French
knowledge is very very limited ok we
have a Catalan oops Catalan bogo hybrid
let's say this is a this is a very
decent line for both sides actually
black has no development problems but
why it has them the bishop pair ok this
is a this is a very um yeah how do you
call it a very conservative way to play
with white not very ambitious black has
absolutely check no problems whatsoever
here to learn to equalize it's a the
only issues it is rather boring let's
see 96 yeah it's very symmetrical
position the only slight issue that
black sometimes experiences is that the
move b6 that was played early on so no
error or anything no mistake the move b6
is somewhat weakening the queenside so
you sometimes have to be a bit careful
that the knight on c6 it's not a stable
peace yeah like rook see one would
attack it and you have to um yeah watch
out that this night is not coming under
understanding some problems that same
but all in all this is a very an
exciting position
this c5 movie some is a good a good way
for equality but not a good way to to do
something active really yeah maybe I
should have played a somewhat more
active active approach there there are
there are those ideas I don't have to
play like that 96 instead of C fibers is
the more interesting move that um that
black has some at his disposal okay so
he wants to play night to be five hmm
yeah that is it is slightly slightly
putting some pressure on me this is
blundering a pawn I shouldn't do that
one so better better go here first
ooh OH
that's nice that's a nice tactic what a
shame I feel that's a neat tactic no I
didn't see that at all I mean I had to
add this hunch that I have to be careful
about the diagonal here Wow so if i take
it I'm losing immediately it's a shame
that was really like a completely
harmless position really but a very nice
tactic chan anyway anyway to fight in
this position it's not easy at all to
put on some some kind of fight and the
problem is that it can just take dhc-6
and it's it's even bishop against night
with the the pass are going to go into
evolve yeah what a shame and with nice
nicely played with Madison it was
actually very harmless i can basically
with precise play i would pre easily
keep it equal but i stumbled into the
deck tech which was which was really
neat ok so let's see and let him display
some some technical yeah and then let
him show some technical ability him
technical ability not tactical there
might be tactics but it's it's tech
taking technical play now ok you will
take play be five I guess we didn't play
be five
ok
and okay probably at some point a for we
win but if not then he has really sport
that Jack
hmm yeah yeah that that is necessary
otherwise some otherwise I will be
drawing here hmm take it be five okay
let's um let's take it first or where
else da to be seven
time warning yeah I cannot calculate
this year and some don't manage that
b6 night c 8 is probably drawing I think
b6 night CA destroying it is I think
Queen may be king be five maybe he can
play King be 58 to be six check you can
just play king be five to draw air to
win I'm sorry what a shame
me
yeah I don't know how but it is it is it
is a drawing drawing position now grin I
have no time so I'm glad that I can
actually end it now with this draw yeah
there was a completely losing end game
but he didn't play it well technically
and the he has to play b5 know obviously
and then that's it then I can safely
resign it's over going here and always
looking at the pawn that that's a very
simple win okay what he did also should
win of course but b5 was was forcing
almost forcing resignation okay here and
now I'm i have the pawn structure on the
queenside on the Kings side and here
only this can be can be the way forward
yeah be 6 p-6 was winning okay b6 was
winning this for Bishop b5 famine and
wins what's the way however to draw a
living I shall i doubt i doubt it
actually yeah wyd wins anyway yeah so he
could have played b5 and made it easier
but it was still winning him it was
still winning and I think even even hear
it was winning a 3b6 he and like here
how does wide window be speedin only be
success is winning and here I'm just
about right with the counter play here
here I king d6 was better of course
kindy 60 impossible but it was sort of
stupid I should go here so then after b7
I can go here
here b7 was what did he do that actually
no we played that one after that I'm
probably drawing yeah it was a surprise
that she didn't do that isn't this isn't
this still a big problem keeping the
porn there was a weird end game he gave
her he gave up Ava b6 and after that I'm
really drawing pretty easily what was
the clear way to draw this one was the
clear way to draw aya because of a
tactic am here and I had a check check I
have this thing and I'm drawing and
notoriously tricky yeah it was a lucky
draw really he then I was should go back
briefly night a 7 it was a very cute
actor yeah I mean here there's simply
nothing going on I just have to be
precise and not blunder into the tactic
something like this is just just
completely equal yeah now intending this
let's say here here I don't know
something like that there's simply
nothing going on this is just completely
commendably should be four again hey not
that one yeah something like that this
is just an equal position nothing's ever
going to happen here where this was this
was really need iya night a seventh in a
very nice tactic after that Jack he's
going to take here and check they win
win easily yeah blundered into that
tactic it was very nice okay thanks for
watching